foreign
welcome back to Harry Potter Theory
Harry Potter didn't win the second
Wizarding War all on his own he needed
allies and the two most powerful members
of his team throughout his entire fight
against Voldemort were undoubtedly Ron
Weasley and Hermione Granger but what if
one of them turned what if one of them
betrayed Harry Potter and aligned
themselves with the Death Eaters today
we're going to answer that question and
more when we take a look at an alternate
future as we ask what if Hermione was a
Death Eater what did she bring to the
table before we talk about just how much
having Hermione and Voldemort's side
would have changed the game let's talk
about what the young witch brings to the
table after all Hermione was much more
than just another one of Harry's friends
before all intents and purposes she was
the brains in Dumbledore's Army and one
of the best strategists that Harry had
in his fight against sword Voldemort
from their earliest days at Hogwarts
Harry and Ron owed much of their success
against the dark wizard to Hermione's
Health from her perfect Brewing of
polyju's potion during the Chamber of
Secrets to her successful hunt for
Voldemort's horcruxes without Hermione
on his side many of Harry's missions
might have never succeeded but the idea
of young Miss Granger joining the Death
Eaters is far scarier than that because
she would bring all those skills and
more to the Death Eaters among her
fellow witches and wizards Hermione was
Leaps and Bounds ahead of the class in
almost every subject when she was only
12 years old she could brew a potion
that most seventh year students would
fear to attempt and she earned better
marks than Harry Potter in almost every
single subject besides defense against
the dark arts she also held a boatload
of inside information about Harry Ron
Dumbledore and the rest of Voldemort's
opponents if you think about it she
wouldn't have joined the Death Eaters in
her first three years at Hogwarts
Voldemort himself didn't signal his
Death Eaters until the end of the trial
wizard tournament that meant Hermione
would have had at least four years of
Intel by the time she joined the cult
group of dark Wizards why would she
change sides of course the Death Eaters
wouldn't just allow a former Harry
Potter Ally to join their ranks without
question and that makes you wonder what
could have made Hermione crossover
Hermione always kept an even head even
when she became jealous of all the girls
who suddenly showed Ron Weasley
attention she never once thought about
dipping into the dark arts and if a
broken heart isn't enough to push
Hermione down the path of becoming a
Death Eater what could of all the likely
scenarios the most probable one is a
threat to her parents during the final
months before the Battle of Hogwarts
Hermione went out of her way to cast a
memory charm on her parents to make them
forget about her and move his far away
from England as possible she did so to
keep them out of Voldemort's clutches
but what if Voldemort got his hands on
them first what if Lord Voldemort
leveraged Hermione's parents and forced
the young wedge to join the Death Eaters
considering how fiercely loyal Hermione
was to her friends and to Dumbledore's
cause she would never abandon them
without good reason and protecting lives
of her parents was certainly the right
call
how would Voldemort use her so if we
follow this thought a bit further we
have to figure out how exactly Lord
Voldemort might utilize Hermione and
based on the Dark Lord's previous
converts I think we have more than a few
ideas let's just go ahead and assume
that some of our previous theories are
right for starters Hermione became a
Death Eater shortly after the end of the
trial wizard tournament and also that
she was initially turned because her
parents were kidnapped but perhaps
eventually she also grew to believe
Voldemort's ideology would Voldemort
really just recruit someone like
Hermione and use her in his day-to-day
attacks against the ministry of magic I
don't think so after all during his
second rise to power Voldemort used the
three unforgivable curses to secretly
gain control of the ministry's staff and
through them he created new laws and
policies that favored his Death Eaters
there was nothing about Voldemort's
second Rise that was as obvious and
risky as his first one of the only
Brazen displays of power occurred during
the final battle at Hogwarts there
Voldemort had his back against the wall
as he desperately tried to defeat Harry
Potter once and for all before the young
wizard could destroy all of his
horcruxes and with this new more subtle
approach Voldemort would have used
Hermione as a secret agent just like
Peter Pettigrew secretly betrayed The
Potters wouldn't Voldemort use Hermione
to betray Harry in the very same way
how things would have turned out in fact
if Hermione ever became a Death Eater I
don't think that Harry Potter would have
survived his fifth year at Hogwarts
during the events of the Order of the
Phoenix Lord Voldemort worked tirelessly
to manipulate Harry Potter using their
strange connection Voldemort allowed
Harry to see visions of the future
whenever Harry received these Visions he
had no idea that Voldemort might have
fabricated them even though Albus
Dumbledore wisely foresaw that issue and
instructed Severus Snape to help Harry
defend against it the young Gryffindor
student couldn't quite grasp the full
picture eventually after witnessing a
vision of his Godfather Sirius Black at
the mercy of Lord Voldemort Harry
decided to act he rang the alarm banded
together with a few members of
Dumbledore's Army and descended onto the
ministry of magic but once he was there
he learned that the vision had been
planted in his mind Voldemort had
tricked Harry into racing Into the Heart
of the ministry of magic hoping that the
boy would track down the prophecy that
the dark lord desperately needed Harry
survived of course thanks to his friends
like Hermione and the sudden arrival of
the Order of the Phoenix Harry lived to
see another day but if Hermione had been
a Death Eater then that night would have
passed much differently throughout the
entire year Hermione would have
encouraged Harry's belief that the
Visions were real and with Voldemort's
help she would have isolated Harry from
Dumbledore's Army it would have been
easy too in that fifth year Albus
Dumbledore strangely tried to cut ties
with Harry of course later on we would
discover that Dumbledore did that to try
and protect Harry but at the time Harry
couldn't help but be heard Voldemort
would have used that to his advantage
and through Hermione would have pushed
Harry to lose faith in the Headmaster by
the end Harry's lack of conviction would
have reflected in Dumbledore's Army and
they would have disbanded not because
they were discovered by Dolores Umbridge
but because they just didn't believe in
the cause anymore
so when Voldemort laid his final trap
and lured Harry Potter to the ministry
of magic Harry wouldn't come along with
his army and Hermione would have made
sure that Harry never uttered his coded
message to Severus Snape they had
padfoot the place where the thing is
hidden in the end Hermione would play
Voldemort's hand perfectly and sneak
Harry into the ministry all by himself
when Harry reached for the prophecy it
would have been just him and Hermione
and once he held the orb in his hand the
Death Eaters would arrive and in that
moment Hermione would reveal her true
colors and switch sides all alone and
without anyone around to help him what
could Harry have done if Hermione truly
became a Death Eater she would have
realized that Harry like any true
Gryffindor was a leader but without his
fellow Wizards and witches by his side
Harry would be powerless against so many
Death Eaters and by the time Voldemort
arrived to finally slay Harry the dark
lord might have learned that complex
truth about killing Harry Potter
especially if he ever allowed Hermione
to study the ancient magical text that
he had acquired Voldemort couldn't
directly kill Harry not with the killing
curse it seemed because of the potion he
used to recreate his new body Hermione
would have discovered that during her
transition to the dark arts and after
she informed Voldemort the dark wizard
would have created a brand new method
for ending Harry's life that night
within the ministry of magic
and with Harry's death there wouldn't be
much hope for the rest of the Wizarding
World Albus Dumbledore was the only
other person who could surpass Voldemort
in magical ability but his fate would
have likely been the same whenever
Dumbledore would eventually try to
acquire all of Voldemort's horcruxes he
would have temporarily lost his senses
and attempted to use the resurrection
Stone on Marvel gaunt's ring in an
attempt to bring back the spirits of his
deceased sister without Harry and
without Albus Dumbledore the entire
Wizarding World would be doomed to fool
to Voldemort's influence for decades
more centuries to come what do you think
would have happened if Hermione switched
sides would Voldemort have even allowed
it a muggleborn given that Voldemort
allowed fenrik raybach to serve him
while not making him an official Death
Eater I think it's possible that he
would have given Hermione the same
treatment and that's it for this video
are there any other what ifs Mario's you
want explored leave a comment down below
until next time remember fear of a name
only increases fear of the thing itself